[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir die
vanitas das ist ein türkisches dessert
und es ist sehr lecker ich glaube selbst
wenn ihr gar nicht so viele
berührungspunkte habe mit der türkischen
küche kann ja sein début liste kennt ihr
schon alle das sind diese krisen
küchlein mit zucker sirup und
zuckersirup ist natürlich auch immer
ganz traditionell in den türkischen
küche und daher starten wir jetzt auch
damit alle ganz gerne annahm stehen wie
immer hier unten in der infobox für den
zuckersirup brauchen wir natürlich
zucker und wasser und das werden wir
jetzt einfach einmal aufkochen lassen
dann kommt noch ein spritzer
zitronensaft dazu dann weitere drei
minuten lang kochen lassen und dann
dieser zuckersirup quasi auch schon
fertig und wir machen mit dem teig
weiter
so für den teig nehme ich jetzt zwar
eine küchenmaschine weil sie hat einfach
mehr power aber wenn ihr keine da habt
nehmt euer handrührgerät und schlag das
ganze einfach doppelt so lang wichtig
ist dass wir richtig viel volumen in die
eier schlagen ich gebe dir jetzt hier
direkt rein und zucker auch schon mit
dazugeben g zucker hilft nämlich nochmal
das noch mal so ein bisschen fester
hinzubekommen und das volumen noch mal
zu verstärken und mit der maschine
brauche ich hier so ungefähr drei
minuten
[Musik]
so das ist jetzt die masse richtig schön
hell geworden und super dick und cremig
genau so muss sie sein und da kommt
jetzt das öl dazu und auch schon der
joghurt ich habe 35 prozent hingenommen
aber eigentlich könntet ihr auch wenn
ihr zufällig zehnprozentigen habt oder
105 prozentigen denn wer das eigentlich
auch kein problem das rühre ich jetzt
nur ganz kurz ein oder wirklich nur so
10 sekunden und dann kommt auch schon
die restlichen zutaten dazu da habe ich
mehl und backpulver das werde ich sieben
und natürlich gries und beim kreis habe
ich hier hartweizengrieß
[Musik]
jetzt schnappt ihr euch eine springform
ich habe hier die 20 cm springform und
da braucht ihr jetzt kein backpapier ihr
müsst sie nicht einführten die hat eine
super antihaftbeschichtung vor allem
weil er jetzt auch fett im teig
abtrainieren zu ganz trockene tage
gehabt dann kann er sicher nicht schaden
aber so brauchen wir es nicht der teig
wird jetzt auch noch schön glatt
verstrichen und wird dann bei 180 grad
ober und unterhitze gebacken ich verrate
euch gleicht die genaue backzeit reichte
es wie gesagt erst mal glatt ganz ganz
wichtig dass er das wirklich so bald es
aus dem ofen kommt nicht abkühlen last
so wie ich sonst immer sage sondern in
dem fall kommt der zucker sirup direkt
nach dem backen drauf da ist man schon
ein bisschen abgekühlt und dann kriegst
kuchen das heiß und dann kann man es
richtig schön durchziehen
[Musik]
genau 30 minuten hattest du dauert und
danach wie gesagt direkt den zuckersirup
drauf geben ihr werdet merken dass er
erst mal gar nicht einsinken und dann
brauchst nur noch ein paar sekunden und
dann saugt der teig des quasi komplett
auf hier habt ihr nur minimal
man sieht kaum minimal tritt was aus das
ist ganz normal aber dafür haben wir
diese auffangen brille und ja so lasst
ihr das jetzt einfach auskühlt am besten
richtig schön durchziehen weil dann
schmeckt er am besten ich gebe jetzt für
vier stunden in den kühlschrank ihr
könnt das ganze auch am vortag machen
und dann schneide ich delhi können
entweder normale kuchenstücke machen
oder er macht so schöne haut und drauf
das mag ich ganz gerne ja ansonsten
werde ich mich an der stelle von euch
verabschieden macht es unbedingt nach
und schreibt neuer feedback dann
unbedingt hier unten in die kommentare
und abonniert auch meinen kanal wenn ihr
keine rezepte verpassen möchte das führt
mich unterstützen und darüber würde ich
mich freuen und dann sehen wir uns auch
im nächsten mal schieben
[Musik]